>>> KANYE WEST, HE IS DIGGING
IN, ISSUING A NON-APOLOGY
APOLOGY IN A NEW INTERVIEW AFTER
HIS ANTI-SEMITIC, ANTI-BLACK
COMMENTS.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> MY QUESTION TO YOU IS DO YOU
NOW REGRET SAYING DEATH CON
THREE ON JEWISH PEOPLE?
ARE YOU SORRY YOU SAID THAT?
>> NO, ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> YOU SHOULD BE.
>> YOU KNOW, I WILL SAY I'M
SORRY FOR THE PEOPLE I HURT WITH
THE DEATH CON -- THE CONFUSION I
CAUSED.
I FEEL LIKE I CAUSED HURT AND
CONFUSION, AND I'M SORRY FOR THE
FAMILIES OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE TRAUMA
THAT I HAD BEEN THROUGH AND THAT
I USE MY PLATFORM WHERE YOU SAY
HURT PEOPLE HURT PEOPLE, AND I
WAS HURT.
>> JOINING ME NOW IS LZ
GRANDERSON, HOST OF THE PODCAST
"LIFE OUT LOUD."
HE ALSO WRITES ON THIS ISSUE.
LZ, YOUR COLUMN IS GOOD ON THIS.
WHAT IS YOUR COMMENT ON THIS?
>> IT'S MORE OF THE SAME.
IT'S MORE TYPICAL ABOUT PEOPLE
NOT WANTING TO BE ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEIR ACTIONS.
THEY NEVER ACTUALLY ACKNOWLEDGE
THE WRONGDOINGS AND TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR DOING IT.
IN THAT ANSWER, I HEARD MORE OF
THE SAME FROM KANYE.
>> LET ME READ PART OF THE PIECE
THAT REALLY STRUCK ME.
I TELL EVERYONE THEY REALLY
SHOULD GO READ THE WHOLE THING.
YOU WRITE YEAR BY YEAR, TRACK BY
TRACKER SNEAKER BY SNEAKER,
TWEET BY TWEET, HE SHOWS US WHY
WE SHOULD FOLLOW AND WHY WE
SHOULD TUNE OUT.
LIKE SO MANY PEOPLE, I KEPT
FINDING WAYS TO CARVE THE
ARTISTRY FROM THE -- IT JUST
STOPPED WORKING FOR ME.
TELL ME HOW YOU GOT TO THIS
PLACE, LZ.
>> IT WAS HARD.
I'M A GENETIC BLACK GUY FROM
DETROIT.
HIP-HOP SHAPED MY GROWTH VIEW
AND WORLD VIEW.
THESE ARTISTS AND RAPPERS, THEY
AREN'T JUST ENTERTAINERS AND
MUSICIANS, THEY'RE ALSO
STORYTELLERS.
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO HELP
DOCUMENT WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
WORLD AS ALL ARTISTS DO, BUT IN
HIP POPP, IT'S PARTICULARLY SO
WITH BLACK PEOPLE.
TO SEE KANYE GO DOWN THIS PATH,
IT HURTS ME.
I USED TOLOVE HIS WORK.
YOU'RE SUPPORTING EVERYTHING
ELSE THAT GOES WITH IT.
IF YOU WATCH A WOODY ALLEN FILM,
YOU NIGHT ENJOY WOODY ALLEN, BUT
HE MAY HAVE SOME ISSUES.
SAME THING WITH MICHAEL JACKSON
AND R. KELLY.
WE ALL HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES, IS
THIS WORKING FOR ME?
IS THIS ARTIST, WHAT HE'S DOING,
DOES IT WORK FOR ME?
WHEN I GOT TO KANYE, THE ANSWER
WAS NO.
>> YOU'RE NOT TELLING PEOPLE TO
CANCEL HIM.
YOU'RE JUST SAYING HE DOESN'T
WORE FOR YOU.
OTHERS ARE SAYING HE NEEDS TO BE
CANCELED.
IT'S BEEN WRITTEN COMPANIES NEED
TO STOP WORKING WITH HIM BECAUSE
HE'S NOT GONE DOWN THE PATH TO
SHOW HE'S APOLOGETIC.
IT'S SAID, THOSE WHO CONTINUE TO
DO BUSINESS WITH WEST ARE GIVING
HIS MISGUIDED HATE AN AUDIENCE.
THERE SHOULD BE NO TOLERANCE
ANYWHERE FOR WEST'S
ANTI-SEMITISM.
>> I AGREE, THERE SHOULD BE NO
TOLERANCE ANYWHERE FOR WEST'S
ANTI-SEMITISM, HOWEVER, THAT'S A
PERSONAL THING.
THE BEST THING I CAN DO WITH MY
PLATFORM IS TO NOT TELL PEOPLE
WHAT TO THINK ABOUT KANYE BUT
ASK THEMSELVES TO TAKE THE TIME
TO THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY THINK
ABOUT KANYE.
DON'T CHECK THE BOX, OH, HE'S
REALLY BEING HIMSELF.
REALLY LISTEN TO WHAT HE'S
SAYING IN THE CONTEXT OF A
POST-2022 AMERICA IN TERMS OF
HATE CRIMES, IN TERMS OF
SEMITISM.
WE'RE IN A CLIMATE NOW THAT'S
VERY, VERY TENSE, AND WHAT KANYE
IS FLIRTING WITH ISN'T
NECESSARILY HELPING, AND SO I
ASK PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, THE CANCEL
MOVEMENT THING, YOU CAN'T CANCEL
SOMEONE AS BIG AND AS POWERFUL
AS KANY